on this morning's dish chef Gabriella
camara the New York Times described her
Mexico City restaurant contra Mar as the
equivalent of New York's four seasons in
its heyday only more fun and with much
better food four years ago Kimura
brought her flair for fresh Mexican
seafood to San Francisco with her
restaurant kala and this year she's
released a cookbook and is the subject
of a Netflix documentary i sat down with
chef Gabriella at Kalla in San Francisco
inside chef Gabriella cámaras san
francisco eatery Kalla fine dining meats
finger food with her Mexican small place
tomorrow brings a lifetime of cooking
experience into the kitchen but no
formal training the former art history
student doesn't think of her food as art
like painting it just happens to come
out that way I would start with these
take Kahlo's signature trout tostadas
with Chipotle avocado and fried leeks
this is sort of our little staple dish
so I wanted to make this for you this is
fantastic
Kumada garnishes her abalone tostada
with trout roe Oh Robbie bonito flake
infused aioli and the blue flowered herb
borage I don't want to eat it it's too
pretty
mmm I love very simple flavors but I
want them to be bright so that's why I
use a lot of acid in lemon and lime
but it's this dish that blends all her
varied influences so this is pasta but
pasta made in a Mexican Spanish way
fried pasta noodles and clams cooked
with liquid tomato and chipotle chili my
mother would say this is not a style
because it what is this deep frying
pasta
delicious yes Kumada is the daughter of
an Italian mother and Mexican father she
was raised in Mexico City what was it
like having those different influences
as a young kid it was great and I we
always had all these periods of time
that we lived in Italy or periods in
which we came to the States or a lot of
traveling because of my parents work and
also just because they really wanted us
to have exposure to to a wider world did
you think that food was your future
though I mean I thought I would always
cook it and eat well but I did open a
restaurant when I was very young and I
had no idea and I realized how much I
loved it Camero was still in college in
Mexico City when she opened her first
restaurant pulled from our with three
friends it was an experiment but we were
very serious about it we wanted it to
work we invested very little money we
all like scrape from our savings here
and there and it happened
almost immediately contramar became a
sensation how do you take what starts as
what sounded like it just started as
let's do this this had to be fun yes and
turn it into the success that it became
I think with a lot of work with a lot of
attention with a lot of caring and I
know that common sense is at least
common sense right but I actually turned
out to be a very good manager just
because I was very my common sense
worked in a restaurant five years ago
Kumada and her family moved to the Bay
Area she was shopping around San
Francisco for a location for a new
restaurant when I found this space and I
thought I need to do something here it's
so good it's it's it's we're sitting in
this is the thing I get it I get it by
sitting here and I saw the beams
I saw the ceiling and I saw that it had
that full block a winning and I really
really loved it so that's why I opened
ala along with the main dining room in
the front combina operates a taco stand
in the back of the building
taco Scala and last month she and fellow
chef Jessica Koslow opened a new
restaurant
onda in Santa Monica but officially
Kumada has moved back to Mexico City
where she's serving as a cultural
adviser to Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador
mexico's president just happened to be a
customer at contramar he was in San
Francisco about two years ago on
business when he stopped by Carla to see
her and he said nobody let this time I'm
gonna win and you're gonna have to come
back to work with me in Mexico and I
thought first you win we've gone through
this twice already two elections that
have been not successful
Lopez Obrador was elected president in
July 2018
Kumada says the chance to serve all the
people of Mexico was impossible to turn
down I think it's worth my time for sure
and my life to give it a shot at helping
him I never set out to serve others as a
mission but I think that now it is my
mission it's just one more thing added
to Commodus plate this has muscles right
and a little bit of chill I said I'm not
but even with the new responsibilities
she's abiding by the old saying don't
quit your day job I think food should be
above anything delicious
and then success yeah food was delicious
but when I tell you this woman is
fascinating watch the Netflix
documentary you spend two seconds with
her really hopefully maybe from this
short time you just want to know more
from her yeah I already put on two in my
couch yeah you got a lot when you're in
San Francisco go to collar the portion
sizes - they're so beautiful but it does
not look like it's over well it's not
share as well yeah good thanks Dan